okay i have a couple sort of like
keeping them honest type stories for you
today
we have been covering the scams grifts
and crony con jobs that have been many
of the contracts given out
during the trump administration and that
includes the ppe company that was only
around for two months with no employees
that was given a massive contract to be
basically a middleman for ppe
back in 2020. earlier this week we
talked about api
checked the company given a 1.3 billion
dollar combination of contracts and loan
loans to make vaccine syringes we're
about 200 million doses in they haven't
even built the factory they've got not a
single
vaccine syringe out there and this next
story
is actually about some of these
so-called deals that donald trump made
back in 2016 and 2017. and even before
being inaugurated in 2016 he announced
one or two and then made some in 2017.
you might remember that donald trump
once bragged
about a supposed 10 billion dollar
deal and factory in wisconsin
that he i guess convinced the company
foxconn
to make he once referred to this deal as
the quote eighth wonder of the
of the world and there was really big
fanfare about it at the white house in
july of 2017
trump saying it's 10 billion dollars
it's 13 000
jobs it's an incredible example of how
i'm doing my america first
thing of manufacturing coming back to
the united states
and it was all going to be incredible it
would be a factory for cutting edge flat
panel televisions and monitors
and it would make wisconsin a
destination for tech firms and
it was all going to be just great but
some of us were suspicious
for a couple of different reasons number
one foxconn is a
sly company with a very charismatic
founder and then chairman
terry goo who is very pr
thirsty and a lot of it seemed like it
was mostly about public relations
and we were also skeptical of these
deals that are really just
hey take some money and do me a favor
rather than economic
policy and indeed there were reports
that even executives at foxconn at the
time were skeptical that this was ever
going to happen
not the least of which was because the
suppliers
for the lcd panels they were supposedly
going to make
were nowhere near wisconsin and it made
very little sense to actually
manufacture those
there case in point the project never
started as described
and now foxconn is announcing you know
four years later now we're going to
scale back what that project is going to
be
and instead of 10 billion dollars
foxconn has announced it will be 672
million
not nothing but that's a 93
reduction in the dollar value of the
project trump
also bragged it would bring 13 000 jobs
to wisconsin foxconn now says well
it's not going to be 13 000 it's going
to be 1454
which is an 89 reduction in the number
of jobs that were promised and that
donald trump
trump announced so should this surprise
us no
but there's another aspect to this i
said at the time
when donald trump and mike pence were
doing their victory tours announcing oh
foxconn is coming to wisconsin
and carrier air conditioner is staying
in i think it was
indiana i pointed out at the time
even if true and of course with many of
these deals as we're now seeing it
wasn't true but
even if true those deals were not
economic policy
they were not scalable they were trump
giving
specific companies a bunch of cash often
in the form of tax breaks or
loans that sometimes don't even need to
be repaid to do a specific thing that
might not even be dictated by the market
like for example foxconn making lcd
panels
in a place that's really far from where
they get all of their parts and at the
time
the foxconn deal was denounced by many
in wisconsin who were rightly saying
this is a tax giveaway to a foreign
company they're getting
they're getting tax breaks they're
getting water rights
they're getting the uh green light
to acquire and demolish houses via
eminent domain to build their factory
it's not economic policy you can't scale
this it's just a handout
trump bought the deal with our tax money
and that's exactly what this is becoming
now
foxconn did start buying houses to
demolish
for their factory uh they are going to
do it eventually but it will be 90
smaller than was promised and in fact
they're not even going to be building a
factory
for the flat panel displays that detail
has also changed they're going to be
making
server components and communications
technology products and maybe medical
devices which is fine
but every detail fell apart from the
original deal and it will be ten percent
of what it was promised to be
five six years later who even knows when
so the project is another microcosm
of the trump presidency in some total
and
and it wasn't just trump taking his
victory laps with this project
then republican governor scott walker
and the wisconsin republican party at
the time were also
loudly bragging and boasting about this
and it is
because it has become absolutely uh
uh it's become pennies on the dollar
what it was supposed to be
riding on our tax money an important
detail
another keeping them honest moment
people are climbing over
donald trump's 15 billion dollar border
wall
with ladders made from five dollars in
raw materials
um we have a new report from the texas
monthly
that the u.s mexico border wall is being
regularly breached
using homemade ladders border patrol
this would almost be a comedy uh if it
weren't a tragedy
border patrol officials are regularly
finding
discarded ladders beside the wall the
walls are
the ladders are so cheap that they just
it's five bucks in
materials and then they just get left
behind and one activist told texas
monthly
that the ladders defeating the wall that
cost 12 million dollars per mile
contained five dollars worth of
ingredients of of
materials u.s border patrol officials
who monitor the wall frequently are
finding
the ladders made by unauthorized
immigrants who cross into texas
along certain parts of the wall the
texas monthly report
cites scott nicholl who's an activist
and texas resident as business insider
reports
saying quote these ladders are probably
five dollars worth of hardware
and they're defeating a wall that cost
12 million dollars a mile in that
location he also added
unlike unlike the wall the ladders are
functional um
trump of course promised to build an
impenetrable wall
across the entire u.s mexico border
by the end of his first term which
mexico would pay for
trump did not build the wall mexico
didn't pay for the little bits and
pieces that trump did build
and it is not impenetrable there are
videos dating all the way back to
when you know years ago of uh people
scaling the wall using a ladder and then
sliding down the other side with about a
hundred dollars worth of stuff from our
hardware store
now they are finding ladders often made
from just a few dollars of scrap
lumber and regularly finding them
all up and down uh that that
that border wall border patrol now
drives around grabbing the ladders
and destroying them and then putting
them together into piles which later are
hauled off into landfills so like ev
every aspect of this is just
mind-numbingly
but mind-numbingly stupid and in total
uh trump after pledging mexico would
fund the work um
mexico didn't pay for it and the 15
billion that went into it came from
federal taxes
and only something like 50 miles of new
50 or 90 new
miles of actual border wall were built
so
we are it's it's going to take years to
learn the full scope
of the scam that was the trump
presidency
sweetheart crony deals that never end up
happening
announcements of jobs and factories that
never end up happening
an impenetrable wall that supposedly
would be completed by the end of the
first term paid for by mexico which
wasn't paid for by mexico and wasn't
completed and was
scalable or or passable with just a few
dollars of discarded lumber it's
all been a major major scam and it will
take some time for us to know the full
scope of it
sad more than anything i take no
pleasure in it um
it's it's humiliating actually when you
talk to people from other countries
what's going on
we have a fantastic program for you
today let me know your thoughts
on the wall failure by finding me
on twitter at d pacman we will take some
of your calls i will answer some of your
questions
and so much more coming up today
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpakman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today okay let's hear
from some of you
in the audience via the david pakman
show discord which you can find
at davidpakman.com slash discord
we use discord instead of a so-called
real phone number now
i feel that the audio quality has
improved
i feel substantively arguably things
have also improved okay let's start
today
with ezana from atlanta georgia asana
you were on the air
hi david hello taking my call pleasure i
wanted to
ask you in light of the derek chauvin
verdict
yes do you think that the conversations
that are being had around police
brutality
systemic racism more broadly
are doing more harm or damage to the
left in terms of
gaining public support and getting the
people we want
elected i don't think that they're doing
more harm than good
but i question whether they're always
doing that much good
does does that make sense yeah yeah i i
kind of see what you're saying can you
elaborate a little on that yeah i mean i
i think that sometimes the conversation
on the left
around police brutality and around race
is disproportionate to the degree to
which something is a problem in the real
world so like
as an example i'm not a class
reductionist so class reductionism would
be
any problem that seems to be about
race or ethnicity or religion really
it's actually about class and if you
deal with inequality in class
the problem gets resolved that's class
reductionism i'm not a class
reductionist and so
but but given that there are times when
as an example when you
look at the number of uh of
of black americans killed by police in
the year
and you look at the amount of
conversation about it
versus the degree to which
economic factors are a huge
role player in poverty and therefore in
education
and therefore in being in neighborhoods
where there is more crime
and where police are paying more
attention rightly or wrongly right i
mean that's
that's a whole other debate sometimes it
feels as though the conversation has
gotten a little bit out of sync
with the proportion to which these
different things are
problems and of course these are all
problems but i would like to see the
conversation maybe a little more
fine-tuned like here let me give you one
other really specific example
it's become very popular now
for police departments and corporations
to announce
in response to what's going on we will
be sending
our officers or our employees to
anti-bias trainings to learn about
implicit bias
is there evidence that that actually
reduces the types of incidents that are
problematic
i've looked for it and i can't find it
so i i worry
that it's more of like a pr thing than
it is actually dealing with the problem
yeah i think i definitely think there is
sort of you know a certain degree of
virtue signaling
that's going on and i don't think it's
always in bad faith
i think a lot of the time it is in good
faith i agree but
i'm uh the the overall thing that i i'm
thinking of this is just more broadly
i'm just wondering if this is you know
some of the reasons why
like trump had so much support um if if
we're going too far with
some of these issues and especially now
because i genuinely thought
january 6th was going to be like the
death of the republican party
it never is the fact that yeah yeah but
the fact that
like trump did an interview the other
night on hannity and that
they seem to still have a lot of uh
energy on their side
i i'm wondering if it's coming back to
these type of issues that
are the reasons for that yeah i don't
i don't i'm not ready to say that it is
you know i i've expressed the
concerns i have but i wouldn't be ready
to make such a sweeping statement
okay all right my friend thank you so
much for the call very much appreciate
it always very very important issue and
one i think that
must be dealt with in a realistic way
you know we shouldn't pretend things are
different if something's a problem we
should deal with the problem rather than
just
insisting it's not a problem let's go
next to stephanie i think it's from
richmond is that stephanie from richmond
virginia
no hi it's uh stephanie from richardson
texas oh sorry
it was cut off richardson texas welcome
stephanie
hi how are you i'm doing well good um
actually i wasn't really had anything
prepared i'm just kind of listening
today
but i actually had to quit and i did
start thinking about a question i wanted
to ask
um about uh since i'm in texas we have a
lot of issues
as you may know um okay
say more about that yeah go ahead no no
i was gonna say tell me more about the
issues yeah
well no there's where do i start so it's
like obviously i watched your uh your
clip the other day about
um how matthew we say mcconaughey from
texas but
matthew mcconaughey has there's he's
thrown his hat in the ring which i don't
know if he would even
you know be a decent um candidate but it
is
evident of how people are starting you
know our climate's changing hopefully
and i'm thinking
like personally i'm wanting to get more
active and like um
uh not i don't know i don't know what
i'm trying to say but like being
more proactive in raising awareness and
so i wouldn't really know how to start
with all that since you seem pretty
educated on the subject of you know
educating people
um i know once the government government
um
races uh candidacy starts and people
start getting um
out there i'm hoping betto decides to
run again
i'm just hoping like i would like some
like advice or tips that you could offer
as far as being um
someone i'm not necessarily shy per se
but i'm not super proactive
so like any suggestions you can throw
out there about like
being someone who i know that
oh boy stephanie we just lost you we
just lost you for a second we just lost
you there stephanie but
here's so here's the thing the great
thing about being a
a progressive in texas is
there are so many opportunities to get
involved to try to unseat a right-wing
nut
so whether it's city councils
mayor's races a gubernatorial race
whatever there's no shortage of
opportunities and you can really make an
impact whereas
you know the truth is you can
participate in local races anywhere
but sometimes it's less interesting to
look at replacing
you know a left-wing democrat with a
five percent more left-wing democrat
it's like you know okay i mean it's a
move to the left but sometimes it's less
rewarding
there are so many opportunities in texas
that you could really get involved in
that and you know if you don't want to
be knocking on doors or calling people
because that's not your personality
there's other things that can be done
you can contact people via text message
there's so many campaigns to get
involved in right and that's what i
think i'm leaning towards because i've
obviously become more uh politically
aware over the last
few years and it's you know something
that i as having a teenage daughter
there's things that are gonna start
impact her life so i definitely want to
get involved and be a little bit more of
a
you know a game changer because we like
i said we have a lot of problems
we need to fix them here because i don't
think we're gonna fix them all but i i'm
sad
because texas really is a great state
but we're getting such a bad reputation
lately
that makes me very sad what um
richardson texas is that in a more blue
or red area i don't i'm not familiar
with it i think that's
pretty red we're um and uh we're our
we're kind of um
north of dallas or suburb of dallas but
yeah as you know dallas is pretty
blue and so is austin oh you know
houston and things like that but
some of the suburbs are definitely a
little bit more red but i think that
my area might be a little bit more
purple i'm hoping
so that you know it's going to be it's
changing because we have a pretty
diverse
um community here where i live so it's
like hopefully things are going to start
to
i don't know change all right well
plenty of opportunities to get involved
stephanie keep us posted
thanks you have a great day all right
stephanie from texas
great to hear from her why don't we go
next
to uh oh i don't know let's go to rob
from east hampton how about
uh hello hello you're on the air oh this
is exciting
um so um i guess i have two questions
but i'll start with the first one um
so the first one i would ask is what is
one position you used to hold
but you sort of changed your mind on now
one position i used to hold but i've
changed my mind on that's
i mean a lot of economic stuff where
you know my initial introduction to
economics in high school
and early in college was just straight
neo-classical economics
and now that i've you know studied
everything from behavioral economics to
marxian economics and everything in
between i i have a much more
uh i would call it real world view
rather than the theoretical neoclassical
view
okay interesting um i asked that because
i
used to like i was a big proponent for
medicare for all
okay um and then after last year um you
know i kind of see that okay yeah you
know
the majority of the population doesn't
want medicare for all so
um i sort of like you know change my
views or i guess i've compromised more
i would say now hold on a second that's
interesting you
what you're not saying you changed your
view on medicare for all because you
found out something about it that you
didn't like
it sounds like you're saying you changed
your view because other people don't
like it
um just in terms of electability it's
not it's
realistically i feel like it's not going
to happen um just because
not that many people um people support
medicare for all but when it comes to
sort of like the intricate details
that's where you kind of see like
support falling off
yeah you're not wrong and i've talked
about that data from the kaiser family
foundation before
which is not part of the the firm kaiser
permanente
my view on this has been i want to get
to universal coverage
with um affordability
and a reasonable standard of care and
in order to do that there's a lot of
different ways
that you can approach it different
countries have approached it in
different ways
i'm not married to medicare for all and
i have a long segment about
other ways it could be arranged as long
as we get to the right
as long as we get to the finish line i'm
open to different ways of running the
race
definitely definitely agree there um i i
just have a really strong bias because
i strongly dislike insurance companies
so i would just prefer a medicare file
system but
again electability wise it isn't the the
most popular thing
um the second question i had and kind of
having a difficulty wording it but
um given biden's handling of the
situation
at the border do you think this and sort
of i would say his lack of
outreach to the hispanic community
during the um
2020 election do you think this can kind
of impact how
um you know midterms go in 2022
i don't think that what will impact the
midterms is
joe biden's outreach or lack of outreach
to the latino community i think that
what will impact the 22 midterms
are is how does the biden administration
react
to right-wing media and republican
elected officials
successfully making immigration
a much bigger issue than it was six
months ago we just looked at polling
which showed that in june of 2020
28 of americans believed that illegal
immigration was a big issue
last month 48 percent of americans
believed illegal immigration was a big
issue this is a win for republicans
because they
know trump failed on kovid and biden has
high approval on it
they know trump failed to jump start
vaccination and joe biden has a really
high approval on it
the the 1.9 trillion stimulus that biden
did
has really high approval so what
republicans are doing is saying
let's come up with something to shift
attention to they've chosen
immigration and it's working so now that
half the country says it's a serious
issue the question is how does biden
deal with it i don't think it's
it's it's outreach to latino voters i
think it's
what does the perception become over
how joe biden is handling the issue and
we don't know yet what it'll be because
we still have a while until the 2022
midterms okay well
thank you so much for taking my
questions all right my pleasure rob from
east is it
is it east hampton new york or
massachusetts uh massachusetts wow okay
what
what's your top restaurant in east
hampton right now
um not gonna lie kisara yeah
yeah yeah yeah i can't go wrong with
casara yep um
all right good okay thanks for the call
rob very very good
let's take a very quick break but if
you're holding don't hang up because
we're taking more calls momentarily
a quick break and right back after this
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
davidpakmanshow okay let's talk to a few
more people we're taking calls via the
david pakman show discord which you can
find at davidpakman.com
discord make sure to become a uh
subscriber to the discord it's free i'm
selling you nothing other than a good
time
let's talk to uh why don't we talk to
maria from ohio maria you're on the air
hello hello hi um
i have one one comment and one question
generally
um my comment is i just really
wanted to say um i appreciate uh lately
i've been noticing
you're you're making an effort not to
stigmatize
mental illness um like the caller
yesterday
and i've noticed i mean uh just just
you know things that you how you treat
uh
the the general i think urges for people
to just
ridicule people who are of the other
side who are clearly mentally ill or
maybe
not clearly but you know suspected and i
just i really appreciate that you're
making an effort to to not further
stigmatize mental illness
um my pleasure that's brad thank you um
and then my question is just if you have
any tips for talking with the older
generation about fixing this
policing issue uh because i have a hard
time talking with my parents about it
they're uh they're in their 70s
and they just their general assumption
is like to assume that
you know they need the the military
militarized gear and everything and need
all of this stuff that clear it's
clearly not
proper to fund that way you know well i
think
i would probe and say
why do you think police departments
should be militarized and they'll have
some answer and then say okay
can you give me some examples of
situations where
police being more militarized helped
there really aren't many i mean it you
know it put
make them just sort of examine how they
came to these conclusions
because what where what what type of pla
were what what part of the world do they
live in ohio maria
yeah yeah we're from ohio yeah i mean in
wherever they live in ohio
are there examples of when police being
more militarized help to resolve a
situation that they can think of
and if there aren't any examples they
can think of then say okay well what
about in the entire state of ohio
or what about in the entire region tell
me exactly how we've been bet we've
benefited
from police being more militarized and
then if you can get them to realize it
actually hasn't really done much for
anybody
then you could go to the next step of
look at the money that's being spent
there aside there's also a fiscal issue
which may may appeal to them in some way
i don't know
yeah thank you yeah i try and talk to
them a little bit about it like
you should kind of be upset that your
tax dollars are being used this way
right there are much better places for
them to be used
you know there's debate over whether we
on the left should use right-wing
framings to talk to people who are on
the right some people say you should
some people say you shouldn't
but it seems that the fiscal thing is at
least worth trying
yeah yeah cool thank you all right maria
thank you maria from ohio
great to hear from you let's try uh
let's go elsewhere
let's go to oh you know who we should go
to we we have to figure out what's going
on
let's go to noog wrangler from
california
noog you're on the air
new grongler you were on the air if you
want to unmute
oh yes hello david for some reason i
didn't unmute sounds like user error i
don't know
yes it must be too many nugs or
something
what can i do for you uh well before i
ask my question
i wanted to clarify that according to a
post
on your subreddit pad callers use
speakerphone would you prefer i use
speakerphone
no no thank you okay okay good well
if that post is wrong and it claims that
bad callers preface their question with
the long monologue
let me begin with mine so it all started
when okay never mind i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna do that um
all right question written down and it's
coming now please
okay so do people that are unhappy with
the employer employee structure of
capitalism
that would rather be in a worker
cooperative
that just isn't there yet now what
message can we offer as progressives
other than maybe like
i don't know cope and weight well
i guess it's not cope and weight it's
start a work or cooperative
right i mean uh it seems that the
quickest way to be part of a worker
cooperative
rather than waiting around is to to get
involved in one and and start one i
don't know what advice i would have
yeah uh yeah sorry for the question i
also was going to say other than you
know start a co-op because it takes a
lot of money
so you're saying if people want more
work or co-ops other than
waiting for it to become more prevalent
coping with the fact that it's not and
other than starting one themselves
what can they do yeah
i maybe i didn't um you know formulate
that question well
no no it's fine i mean i maybe call your
elected officials
and encourage them to i don't know
pass maybe preferential tracks a tax
treatment for worker co-ops maybe
there's something there
uh that could maybe you know look at if
you want to operate at the city or town
level
look at maybe grants for worker co-ops
on
rent subsidies or something like i don't
know any you know anything that would
make it more
appealing i guess for a company to be
structured that way
actually calling an elected rep sounds
like a good idea yeah
okay well uh you know thanks thanks for
taking my call all right
there it is noog wrangler with a uh
very specific question which we love
which we love
let's go next to um
but there's just so many people that are
wanting to get on let's go to avi from
california
avi you're on the air
uh hey david um so after the
trial derrick shelvin after he was found
guilty i hopped on a right-wing
telegram and it was a lot of people were
getting pissed off
i thought it was a guilty verdict yeah
and it wasn't just a small sentence like
thousands of people
so what would be the best approach to
try to explain
to me these people like in real life
about why
he was found guilty see the thing that's
tough about this
is anytime you're not
you know part of the try i mean some
people watched
all of it okay but very often people
just react and say
it was the wrong result because it's not
the result that i wanted
because of what it means politically or
culturally rather than this was an
adjudication
by the jurors in the room of the facts
in the case and applying those facts
to what the law is there have been lots
of
trials where the verdicts have been
things i didn't want
but you have to respect the verdict
because you're not one of the jurors
in this case i believe that the verdict
does actually do something in terms of
hopefully signaling to police that that
there will be accountability
um so i don't you know to me it's less
about
convincing anyone that the verdict was
right or wrong
but more about the fact that if this is
the way we adjudicate these things
then it was fairly decided by a jury and
we have no choice but to stand by that i
i'm
i'm not that keen on arguing about the
merits of the case
um i and a lot of my commentary in the
aftermath looking at right wing
media going completely bonkers is that
they sort of seem to be abandoning their
own principles about how we decide guilt
or innocence
because in this case they wanted not
guilty whereas it's like
it do do you respect that this is the
system we have or don't you
yeah it seems like they want criminal
justice for them but not for everyone
else
it's like with many of these things it's
like with medical issues
it's like with uh debt and deficit it's
they
they claim that they have certain values
but then as soon as those values
and infrastructure lead to an outcome
they don't want they throw away the fact
that they
claim to re respect the system we have
it's pathetic
is it a signed question that's awesome
sure yeah
um what are your thoughts on modern
monetary theory oh i have i have uh
close to 10 clips about it uh i i've
done a bunch of interviews with some of
the top mmt people i mean generally
speaking my view is
a dollar of debt is not created equal
and what matters is what are we deficit
spending
in order to fund is it economically
stimulative or
isn't it and that's the way we should be
thinking about the national debt
all right thank you all right avi from
california
great to hear from you let's go next to
haley from georgia hayley you are on the
air
hey david this is the first time i've
called in great uh welcome
hi so my question um kind of starts off
with you know i'm from georgia i live in
augusta it's the second most populous
city in georgia and we um
are kind of split by two different
counties one very blue one very red
um we worked extremely hard to remove
corrupt officials in the 2020
election based on the majority vote of
our entire state
like electing senators and electing joe
biden sure and still
it was extremely close um we almost
didn't give our electoral votes to biden
we almost didn't elect warnock but
district by district
there are many republicans that are
running unopposed in the general
assembly
and it's impossible to change our state
laws and our congressional
representation
um i've known a lot of our our
population is tired um from all this uh
all these elections um what more do you
think that we can do
in 2022 to ensure that we don't lose
warnock
and also to change our state
representation
well the it's very important for people
to understand
that politics is much more than just
getting involved in presidential
or senate or even u.s congressional
seats and as you point out
a lot of what is being done when you
look at education
when you look at abortion when you look
at broadband i mean like all of these
issues
are hugely determined by the state
legislatures and state senates and so
i think what what we have to do is
constantly remind
people that particularly in places like
georgia with unopposed republicans
they have to start being opposed you
have to start mounting campaigns from
the left and there's no shortage of
opportunities to get involved
it's really i think it's just really a
reminder haley a lot of people just
think about they vote for senate they
vote for president
and then that's basically it and you
have to start earlier
and you have to start building
candidates that can actually challenge
some of these republicans now
some of them may just win because a lot
of the way that the the
state is sliced up um is good for
republicans
and so we have to we have to understand
that that we're up against that as well
but if they're unopposed then you don't
even have a shot
right i know it's so unfortunate yeah
thank you for answering my question i
just wanted to get that out there to
everybody too
yes and get involved in state senate
state legislature like haley is saying
yes all right haley thank you
yellow okay haley's gone thank you very
much haley
very important and that applies to just
about every state i would say every
state really
um okay why don't we go next to nisha
from michigan nisha you're on the air
oh my god uh hi dave how are you doing
i'm doing well thank you okay well i
um i've actually been um looking at your
show on
youtube i'd say ever since 2019.
beautiful i'm pretty much a fairly fan
um
i was also on yesterday but uh i know
you couldn't reach me because there's a
lot of people
um so the whole thing with the uh derek
shoving case i was
as shocked as you were so
i actually didn't even think that they
were gonna do it but i'm glad that they
uh that they did um uh
i don't even know what i could actually
say as a question because i'm a little
i'm a little bit nervous
you're doing great well listen let me
ask you this
what is happening in michigan with covid
which
has been very up and down and much
controversy over covet guidelines
yeah i think uh as of right now
i've even been checking about it myself
so i mean
it's like half and i guess half and half
i was actually talking to uh one of my
friends i think uh some days ago and she
said that she was um
not really um thinking about getting the
um
vaccine and i pretty much was telling
her like well
if you i already said like if you don't
want to get the astrazeneca one
of course yeah no that's fine because
that has blood clots and also yeah
astrazeneca is not even approved in the
united states did you mean johnson and
johnson
and the johnson and johnson one of
course is you know
that too but i had told her that i had
my um i i do have a i did get i'm half
vaccinated so i dig in my um
moderna vaccine along with my husband
and my mother
beautiful so i have pretty much told her
about i
pretty much i told her if you if you
want to go and do either the pfizer or
the madonna vaccine you
can be able to do that and she pretty
much still said that she was uh
skeptical
and what is she skeptical of is she
skeptical that it works is she skeptical
of side effects
maybe it might be because of side
effects
i'm not sure but she had told me that i
think her
auntie and her grandmother had got it
and they were fully vaccinated
yeah and i pretty much said well that's
at least enough proof there they're
still you know
alive and well they're walking and
whatnot so i'm like that could at least
be proof right there that it's
yeah but i mean it's also like you know
hundreds of millions of people around
the world have now been vaccinated it's
weird when it's like
your aunt or something like that my my
approach would be this nisha i would
always say
what is making you hesitant to get it
because sometimes people say i don't
know that i want to get it and it could
range from
i think there's a bill gates microchip
in it to i think there will be long-term
side effects too i don't know that it
works too i don't want you know whatever
so
try to figure out what is the reason for
the hesitancy and deal with that
i don't know because the whole thing the
whole bill gets thing i think that is
way too far fetched because that just to
me does not make
any type of sense i agree with you yeah
i know i know she would not go that far
right okay okay fair yeah just ask what
the hesitation is
comes from and then deal with that
head-on yeah and she
well and also she had told me that she
wanted to go and wait a year
i was like uh okay yeah i don't think
that's really like a good idea
i'm not a really good idea because i
mean
if you were to go in at least well i
kind of don't want to make it
kind of sound like that like pretty much
if you want to go on uh you know
you know for us to hang out again and
whatnot and also go and see
um you know my baby so yeah i mean you
know
i mean at least get vaccinated or
something at least that's maybe some
reason i didn't want to frame it like
that
sure and i don't think i even told i
don't think i even told her
it i don't think i told her like that in
that way either so yeah all right well
good
good luck in michigan nisha said it's
going in the right direction but it's
not happening maybe as quickly as we
would like it's actually nisha though
nisha okay i apologize it's okay it's
sorry
nisha a perfect phone call i appreciate
it
thank you okay thank you there is nisha
from michigan let's go next to
rj from wisconsin rj you're on the air
hi there you hear me i can hey thank you
for taking my call
i just want um say i you know personally
i'm fairly relieved about the
result of yesterday's trial and it seems
that uh upwards of maybe 85 to 88
percent of america is as well
but i guess i want to touch on you know
something that's been coming up in the
news
and that's the um shooting that occurred
in columbus as well
and all the protests that are coming as
a result of that
right i watched that video
several times um and you know obviously
nobody knows the
exact details of that yet but i guess my
question to you is
do we need to
in some ways draw a line to where we're
willing to
protest some of these things if use of
force is
is is use of force ever a justifiable
method from law enforcement and
is there a line that we are going to
draw
you know as democrats or as
as liberals that um
we would be willing to accept any reason
for
use of force by a police officer or wait
so
are you are you saying are there any
circumstances where it's okay for police
to use deadly force is that your
question
well yeah i guess in what circumstance
would that be okay
i mean it looked to me from the video
and i'm again i'm just
going off of what i've saw seen in in
slow motion
by less but you know it looked like the
one individual had had
possibly a knife or something like that
that was going after another individual
well listen i haven't i haven't seen
this specific video
but certainly there are of course there
are situations where police use of force
up to deadly force
is is warranted uh what we want
is for uh as a society
to have a really good feeling that
police
are good at determining when that's
appropriate and you can go through all
sorts of different scenarios an
active gunman and police show up
certain hostage situations someone who's
about to set off a bomb i mean
the the i i recognize and accept
the the legal framework in which police
are able to use
up to deadly force but i think that the
debate i've not heard
any lib i mean okay i guess there's some
people who don't want police at all and
maybe they would say police shouldn't
ever
even fire a gun no matter what it's more
far left
99 of everybody 100 of everyone i've
personally spoken to
uh understands that sometimes police use
deadly force and it's a is appropriate
right and i guess i guess my question is
is is
you know there are clear instances where
obviously
you know police intervention need you
know and use of deadly force
is necessary yes but you know given that
you know i guess in in terms of of
going forward with protests and things
like that if we're
you know are we willing to on our side
acknowledge the fact that maybe
there is you know in it say in that
situation if they had you know if the
individual did have a knife and was
going after
after the other individual you know are
we willing to accept that
yes because that was an african-american
that was that was
you know unfortunately shot by by a
white police officer
that were willing to admit that you know
that was that was a justifiable use of
of force in that instance listen you'd
have to ask
people who i guess are on some other
side of this
my my view is that just the race of the
of an officer and the race of the person
that gets shot
doesn't tell you whether the actions of
the officer were acceptable that's my
position you know
you're getting into a lot of other other
things that don't really
reflect my views so i would maybe talk
to people who are more of that of that
mindset i appreciate the phone call very
much and it's an
important question um but i think that
it's also important not to
i mean police should never use force
period is not one i've really heard
so i'm not inclined to spend too much
time arguing about it because it seems
99.9 percent of the country is is on the
same page on that
okay i'm up i apologize i wasn't able to
pick up
more phone calls i did what i could we
will take a break and we will take calls
again
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what pat
does
all day very very concerning to a lot of
people all of that and more on the david
pakman show
instagram account at david pakman show
okay let's jump into audience questions
for the week first question
about guns david why have mass shootings
skyrocketed in the united states it is
true that mass shootings have increased
in the united states
there is unlikely to be a significant
agreement on this issue politically
right now
but to me it seems very clear that there
are at least a few factors that together
have led the united states to be in the
situation that it's in now
for the people that focus only on guns
i actually don't think guns are the
problem
they are a major problem in the united
states the easy availability of firearms
combined with the lack of a universal
background check program
the lack of an insurance requirement uh
the
uh ease with which you can purchase
large capacity magazines i mean
there's a lot that relates to guns but
there are countries like switzerland and
i know it's almost cliche to even bring
it up at this point in time
there are countries with high rates of
gun ownership that do not have
our gun violence problem and that is
because of something else and i believe
that it is a result of
culture and by culture i mean gun
culture in the united states
the idea that in the united states more
than in
so many other of the rich oecd countries
in the united states there's this idea
where people see firearms
as a solution to problems as a solution
to interpersonal problems
as a solution to being an incel i mean i
know it sounds weird but like
that's also a factor in some of these
shootings in individual cases
it's a solution to work problems it's a
solution to political problems in the
eyes of many
that is very different than in other
countries and so
when you look at things like should we
have universal background checks well
yeah of course
uh when you look at the 2004 uh the the
federal assault weapons ban which
expired in 2004
there were there was a spike in
shootings uh
after that expired but there is a debate
as to the degree to which it is
responsible because there was also
um the sort of uh furthering
of this wacky right-wing gun culture at
that point in time
during the era of george w bush and so
it seems clear that there is a unique
set of circumstances in the united
states which is
culture which includes ignorant people
it includes people who see guns as a
solution to problems
availability of guns yes and then also
you know lack of access to mental health
care
and the fact that even for people who do
have access it's often highly
stigmatized extremism there is a lot of
extremism in the united states
um compared to many other countries
which leads people
to look for things like guns with which
to
then go and do things so my point here
is not
to say uh that is that that it is
one issue at the exclusion of others or
that we shouldn't be looking deeply
at gun safety itself we absolutely
should
but we need to understand that there is
also something special in the united
states
a lot of these movements that in other
countries are
hyper fringe like hyper hyper fringe
in the united states they are fringe but
it's a big enough
country where there's still a lot of
them 60 minutes
um segment over last weekend about the
oath keepers
which um is one of these right-wing
militia type
groups these things exist i get it
there's this right nationalist front in
many uh european countries and you know
australia has examples of these groups
australia has very different gun law i
think it's important to say but there is
a huge cultural component which if we
ignore
we need to focus on the gun piece
because we're humiliatingly behind on
dealing with guns
but there's also something special and i
don't mean in a good way
about american culture that correlates
uh and
and i believe is causally related to
these shootings as well hey david is
there anyone who would run against
trump in the republican primary instead
of letting him have the nomination if he
wants it
this is a great question the context is
that last week
former ambassador to the u.n nikki haley
said even though at one point a few
couple months ago
she was kind of critical of trump she
said um if trump runs i wouldn't run
in 2024 and if trump runs i would
support
donald trump i think most of the people
right now that are
contenders for the republican primary in
2024 would get the hell out of the way
and let trump have it
just to mike pompeo trump's secretary of
state has mentioned
i don't even think pompeo's a candidate
but there's no there's no chance in hell
that pompeo runs against donald trump
if pompeo's thinking about it and trump
runs pompeo's out of the way
i don't think mike pence would run
against donald trump that would be
really weird
former vice president running against
the person they served under
don't think it's going to happen ron
desantis is being mentioned the
republican florida governor who's
horrible in every way uh he would not
run against
donald trump um josh hawley who was one
of the first
defiantly and and and proudly uh
opposing the certification of the 2020
election results he's not running
against trump
ted cruz not running against trump
christie gnome the south carolina
governor she's a trump suck-up she's not
going to run against him lindsey graham
forget about it
uh rick scott uh i don't see any of
these people actually challenging trump
unless something dramatic were to happen
around the 2022 midterms i uh
i i think that the the people who would
stay in if trump runs
are the people who would be running
because they don't like trump people
like
mitt romney uh who else i don't even
know
i can't even think of anybody else mitt
romney types
are the ones that wouldn't get out of
the way for trump
because they are not trumpists
fundamentally and
i think that trump's 2024 future
will be far more determined by trump's
physical health at the time
and whether trump's urge for revenge and
pettiness
override laziness and i think that
trump's spending four years at
mar-a-lago
the idea of of i mean i get you know the
the campaign
fuels his narcissism the crowds and the
speeches and the media coverage there's
no doubt about it
but at the same time he's not a
particularly healthy guy
he'll be close to 80 at that time i
think he will be relatively bored and
complacent
and it will really be trump who
determines
what happens in 2024 as of right now if
it
if it's trump versus romney today i
think trump certainly wins trump has the
support of the vast majority of the
republican party
but don't expect a challenge to trump by
anyone from within
the trumpian circle could could uh liz
cheney maybe challenge trump yeah maybe
somebody like that
uh condoleezza rice i don't know i'm
thinking out loud but most of the people
that have been around trump
are not going to challenge donald trump
uh if donald trump decides to run
hey david i saw an article that
australia is now ranking
soda as healthier than fruit juice what
do you think
is soda healthier than fruit juice this
is not a nutritionist
uh type show and i'm just going to give
you my opinion
based on everything that i've read uh it
is true
that if you go simply buy a grams of
sugar
you could make the case that fruit juice
is less healthy than soda
in the sense that it is laden with more
grams of sugar
now if you are getting the sugar
from naturally occurring fruit sugar
versus for example high fructose corn
syrup in a soda
my instinct is the the fruit sugar is
probably preferable
but that being said there's an
interesting story about how orange juice
got branded as a healthy part of a
balanced breakfast
and the reality is that squeezing the
juice only
out of a fruit like an orange and having
the juice of what i mean
a glass of juice is what the juice of
three oranges
four oranges something like that absent
the fiber and nutrients of the pulp
doesn't seem particularly healthy now if
you say you know i don't i don't really
drink fruit juice
i'll occasionally make a juice at my
house and it'll be like you know one of
these
uh beet carrot orange apple juices it's
half vegetable juice or whatever
i i don't think it's the healthiest
thing but okay in the summer i may
indulge
um i i haven't had soda and i don't even
know how long other than the occasional
foreign coke which is sweetened with
sugar instead of corn syrup
if you give me the choice i'm probably
still choosing the juice
um maybe in a smaller portion than than
what others might
but the point is i understand the
australian
health star ratings are focused
exclusively on sugar content meaning
grams of sugar
and under that paradigm you could make
the case that the soda
is better it it doesn't really pass the
sniff test for me
particularly because the
source of a lot of those sugars and soda
combined with all of the other
ingredients don't strike me as healthier
so my suggestion is just eat whole fruit
eat an actual fruit
uh and instead of orange juice for
breakfast maybe have an actual orange or
a half orange or half a grapefruit or
something like that
um my my uh this is not advice
but i stick to water
unsweetened coffee drinks tea
with no sugar or occasionally a little
bit of honey
um and then just sparkling water and
don't need sodas in my life and if i'm
having juice it's my homemade juice
okay oh and just one other thought on
this a lot of parents will start giving
their kids juice
pretty young and i know two
pediatricians
and they've both said disaster disaster
you are tuning the sweet
tooth of kids really young if you start
giving them juice
when they are very little um in terms
of uh if if you want to give juice they
say
water it down dramatically where it'll
sort of like look like juice colored
but it's at least half if not three
quarters or 80 percent water i'm not a
parent but that seems quite reasonable
to me
okay so that's my answer having no idea
about this stuff
um and just answering what people ask me
make sure
that you are following me on the new
platform
on which we are uh publishing content
and engaging
bitclout you can find it at
davidpakman.combitclout
i am setting up a direct message channel
directly to me
for our top 20 pacman
holders on bitclout what does that even
mean
if you're curious go to
davidpakman.combitcloutbitclout and
check it out
we'll have more about it next week and
we have a great bonus show coming up for
you in mere
moments how do you get access to the
bonus show
if only it were simple it is you become
a member at joinpacman.com and that's it
see you then
you